okay so are we just gonna do this
forever i assume yes i assume there will
be oh mercrat and then we'll move on to
whatever the next letter of the greek
alphabet is and we'll just keep going
we'll just keep going five years from
now there will be a new variant be like
wow this one's even more transmissible
than the last one be like yeah but
nobody's dying people will be and all of
our leaders but yes but it's more
transmissible like but no one's dying
nope more transmissible
this is insanity okay now the reason
again that i'm focused in on the
deadlines is because who cares if it's
more transmissible if there aren't more
people getting hospitalized and dying
okay right now
and it's amazing the authorities we are
supposed to listen to are the people who
know the least
okay so i'm gonna give you the person
who knows the most okay this is the
south african doctor angelique cozy she
identified omicron in south africa
here she is explaining what omicron is
and what it is not
the overall
patience
that was recorded yesterday was three
thousand and around about three thousand
seven hundred so our positivity rate is
nine point two um two percent
it is yes it is it is
more than we would have loved
um it to be
but looking at the mildness of the
symptoms that we are seeing currently
there is no
reason for panicking
as we don't see severely ill patients
so then what the
what in the hell are we are we talking
about we're shutting down the globe
again the stock markets are dumping
because they're afraid that all these
morons who run our governments are just
going to shut everything down and the
doctor who discovered the variance in
south africa was like yeah we're seeing
mild disease
no increase in hospitalizations no
increase in deaths
are you all insane have you all lost
your damn the answer is they love the
control they love it so much and they
know again that the political the
political arena is stacked in favor of
control you want your politicians to you
know it's our fault it's our fault we as
individual human beings living in
democracies we want our leaders to do
something do something save us protect
us here's the thing they can't
they cannot the only thing that our
leadership was capable of doing during
this entire pandemic was throwing money
at the big pharma companies and big
pharma companies came up with an answer
so
that's it those are all the things that
is what government has been able to do
but you out there you somehow think that
if your leader tells you to stay home
your leader has done you a favor your
leader has not done you a favor your
leader is an idiot your leader knows
less than this doctor
yeah i'm listening to the science she's
a doctor is she not the science but no
we're supposed to listen to dr anthony
fauci
who again has pretzeled himself into a
human aroboros by shoving his head so
far up his ass it's coming out his head
again
we're supposed to listen to him who's
been wrong every single step of the
pandemic but not the lady who discovered
omicron not that lady
you can't listen to her because she's
saying it's a mild disease
over in the uk
they're going to boost mask wearing they
said that anyone arriving in england
must take a pcr test for coven 19 on the
second day after the arrival and
self-isolate until they provide a
negative test if someone tests positive
for the omicron variant he said their
close contacts will also have to
self-isolate for 10 days regardless of
vaccination status
okay regardless of vaccination status so
before if somebody was a close contact
got coven and you're vaccinated you
didn't have to isolate
now because of omicron they have to
isolate
okay meanwhile many countries have
slapped restrictions on various southern
african countries including australia
brazil canada the eu iran japan new
zealand thailand and the united states
also
i i should note here that um israel
actually shut its borders to all
travelers again
again so that was great they were open
for like 12 hours
and then the israeli government because
again again all politics is stacked in
favor of lockdown fanatics
the israeli government was like no one
comes in again and by the way if you do
come in and you get a special
dispensation the way that it works in
israel you have to take a pcr test you
have to stay in a quarantine hotel until
you take the pcr and get the results
then even if you come up negative you
have to quarantine for a week
wherever you're going and so you take a
second negative pcr test everyone has
lost their minds you wonder why the
markets are dumping it is not because of
omicron it's the markets are dumping
because the markets recognize that a
bunch of political leaders who are
stupider than your typical kitchen sink
are running the place
how much is politics infusing how we do
public health these days you know why
this thing is called omicron you know
why the reason why is because they
didn't want to name it new okay new was
the next
one in the in the greek alphabet and
they were afraid that people are stupid
enough to think that if it was called
the new variant they'd be like oh you
mean the new variant like n-e-w
so even if they had who cares but the
real reason is because the one after
that
is sai
okay sai which is the greek letter sai
it is spelled x-i
and you know what else is spelled x-i
the name of china's leader xi jinping
okay so even though they are not
hourly different right a-u-r-a-l-l-y
they're not or they they sound they
sound different to the ear
when you spell them
they look the same right the greek
letter psi is spelled x-i and so is xi
jinping
and so who was like well we don't wanna
we don't wanna make that we don't wanna
remind people this thing came from china
that would cause racism
uh you people you people
a spokesperson tarek jasserevek said
quote nu is too easily confounded with
new and tsai was not used because it is
a common last name oh really
is that what this is you know delta is
kind of a common name too like we have
an entire airline called delta here in
in the united states i noticed also
alpha is a pretty commonly used term so
says beta
so is gamma
i i'm noticing that um your your
sudden shyness about using the greek
alphabet started right about the time
that your chinese pay masters got
uptight maybe we should call it the
winnie the pooh variant in order to make
sure that the uh that we are
not targeting xi jinping who definitely
definitely does not look like winnie the
pooh 100 does not look like winnie the
pooh
okay so
we don't know anything about this virus
okay the only thing that we know about
omicron is that it has more spiked
proteins which means that it is more
transmissible and may evade whatever vax
immunity was provided for that spike
protein okay by the way what the studies
tend to show is that natural immunity
has a has a broader spectrum of disease
prevention than does vaccine immunity
according to the israeli studies
specifically because the the vaccines
really target only one spike protein
whereas natural immunity can cover more
than one it covers a sort of gamut
okay so here is dr anthony fauci the
greatest of all doctors and he says well
you know the big risk here is that it
appears more transmissible yes we know i
don't care
i don't care i assumed every i already
once i assume 100 of people are either
going to get immunity through natural
immunity or vaccines there's no more
than a hundred percent there's not a
hundred and one percent of humans
okay it doesn't work that way so once
i've already made that assumption you
can't scare me by telling me that more
people are going to get it i know
everybody's gonna get it i'm aware
and by the way pfizer has already come
out and they said oh yeah by the way we
can rework the vaccines pretty quickly
so if it turns out that this does evade
immunity in some severe way within 100
days we can rework the pfizer vaccine in
order to in order to
generate new immunity anyway here's
here's anthony fauci trying to freak you
out about the transmissibility of this
disease
it has the molecular characteristics
that would strongly suggest
that it would be more transmissible it
has a bunch of mutations a disturbingly
large number of mutations
in the spike protein which is the
business end of the virus which really
binds particularly in one particular
component of that spike that binds to
the receptors in your body in your nose
and your in your nasopharynx and in your
lung the mutations would strongly
suggest
that it would be more transmissible and
that it might evade some of the
protection
of monoclonal antibodies and
convalescent plasma and perhaps even
antibodies they're induced by vaccine
okay but here is the thing if you evade
the the antibodies that are induced by
the vaccine that doesn't mean that you
don't have t cell and b cell memory that
can still help you your body know how to
fight this thing and also again we have
therapeutics coming online we have so
here's the question for anthony fauci
there he is scaring the crap out of
everybody scaring the pants out of
everybody right they wow you know they
might evade the vaccines
okay one what are we talking about are
we talking about evading the vaccines so
far as infection or are we talking about
evading the vaccines so far as the
hospitalization and death rate again the
only person i have heard who knows
anything about the hospitalizations and
deaths is the south african doctor who
discovered this thing who said it's
causing mild disease why is everyone
freaking out
but i'm going to listen to anthony fauci
okay so then anthony thought she's asked
does this cause more severe disease he's
like i don't know
i don't know is not good enough for you
to lock down the entire society again
especially because it didn't work the
first time even by the way if it did
cause higher
rates of hospitalization and death
you would have to explain why lockdowns
are the solution to that because they
weren't the first time sweden didn't
lock down and sweden now has the 56th
highest death per million rate
okay everyone is ripping on sweden
sweden did better mostly all y'all
here's anthony fauci again admitting he
doesn't know if this causes more death
do we know if it causes more severe
disease
great question george and we don't know
that in fact we were on the phone with
our south african colleagues who have
been incredibly good
about being so transparent about what's
going on there on friday and we're
meeting with them again today late a
little bit later on in a couple of hours
to try and find out if the cases that
they've identified that clearly are
caused by this variant what is the level
of severity in that hopefully it would
be light but you know south africa has a
relatively small proportion of the
population that's vaccinated so you got
to take that into the equation when
you're trying to figure out where this
virus is really going and what its
impact is going to be
okay so in other words you have given us
like the wrong information you just want
to scare the living daylights out of us
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content